[موسيقى] هو دكتور فاوتشي يعلم أن الكذب على الكونجرس جريمة ، هل ترغب في التراجع عن تصريحك في الحادي عشر من مايو حيث زعمت أن Nih لم يمول أبدًا مكاسب لأبحاث الوظيفة في وو على السناتور بول لم أكذب أبدًا قبل المؤتمر وأنا لا أتراجع عن هذا البيان الذي كنت تشير إليه ، تم الحكم على هذه الورقة التي كنت تشير إليها من قبل موظفين مؤهلين أعلى وأسفل السلسلة حيث لم يتم اكتساب وظيفة ما سمح لي بإنهاء تناول فيروس حيواني وقمت بزيادة هذه القابلية للانتقال إلى البشر ، صحيح أنت أقول إن هذا لن يعمل ، نعم هذا صحيح ، والسيناتور بول أنت لا تعرف ما الذي تتحدث عنه بصراحة تامة وأريد أن أقول إنك رسميًا لا تعرف ما الذي تتحدث عنه [الموسيقى] إنها رقصة وأنت ' إعادة الرقص حول هذا الأمر لأنك تحاول إخفاء المسؤولية عن أربعة ملايين شخص يموتون حول العالم من جائحة أن ما فعلناه كان مسؤولاً عن وفاة فرد أنا مستاء تمامًا من أن  د إذا كان أحد
يكذب
هنا السناتور فهو أنت